ORIGIN.
>> Bret: JENNIFER GRIFFIN LIVE
IN THE PENTAGON.
TREY YINGST IS STANDING BY LIVE,
WHAT DO YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU
HEAR ON THE GROUND?
>> GOOD EVENING, WE ARE STILL
GATHERING INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
ATTACK IN WESTERN IRAQ TOWARD
THE MILITARY BASE THAT HOUSES
U.S. TROOPS.
THE IMPORTANT THING TO REMEMBER
IS ACCORDING TO IRANIAN STATE
TELEVISION, THESE ARE BALLISTIC
MISSILES, SURFACE TO SURFACE
MISSILES THAT HAVE BEEN FIRED.
THIS IS A MAJOR ESCALATION, IF
CONFIRMED DUE TO THE FACT THAT
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST AS
MORTARS AND ROCKETS BEING FIRED
TOWARDS AMERICAN AND IRAQI
BASES, MOSTLY RUN BY THE IRAQIS
BUT HOUSING AMERICANS.
IF THIS IS CONFIRMED TONIGHT,
THE NUMBER WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GET FROM OFFICIALS AND
JENNIFER GRIFFIN REPORTING AT
THE PENTAGON, A MAJOR
ESCALATION.
SOMETHING PEOPLE IN BAGHDAD HAVE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT.
THEY ARE EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT IS TO COME.
THERE WAS A CALM BEFORE THE
STORM FEELING IN BAGHDAD TODAY
BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS BEFORE, KNOWING
HOW QUICKLY CONFLICT CAN ERUPT
IN THE REGION.
IT IS A MAJOR CONCERN, IF IRAN
DOES LAUNCH A MAJOR
COUNTERATTACK AFTER THE
AMERICANS TOOK OUT THEIR
MILITARY LEADER QASEM SOLEIMANI
LAST WEEK.
IT COULD EVOLVE INTO A MUCH
LARGER CONFLICT, WE ARE LOOKING
AT A PROXY WAR IN THE REGION,
MOSTLY SMALL ATTACKS ON IRAQI
BASES THAT HOUSE AMERICAN
TROOPS, MORE THAN A DOZEN OF
THEM OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
BALLISTIC MISSILES ARE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THING IN
THE REGION AND COMING FROM
IRANIAN TERRITORY, THIS LEAVES
ALL OPTIONS ON THE TABLE FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE ARE GETTING A STATEMENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, FROM STEPHANIE
GRISHAM THE PRESS SECRETARY
INDICATING THE PRESIDENT IS
AWARE OF THE SITUATION AND HAS
BEEN BRIEFED AND IS CONSULTING
WITH HIS NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM.
LOOK FOR MORE RESPONSE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE THROUGHOUT THE
EVENING, THAT IS THE BIG
QUESTION NOW.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PROMISED HE
WILL RESPOND STRONGLY.
HE MADE MANY OF THOSE COMMENTS